now even more out of touch the president
of the san francisco federal reserve
bank who makes nearly half a million
dollars a year suggesting americans
should stop complaining about inflation
because they have enough you have enough
listen to this
i
don't the pain of inflation anymore i
see prices rising but i have enough that
i can make substitutions that i can do
things so i'm not immune to gas prices
rising food prices rising i sometimes
balk at the the price of things but i
don't find myself in a space where i
have to make trade-offs because i have
enough many many americans have enough
you have enough stop being so greedy
don't be a greedy capitalist here now
with reaction fox business anchor
charles payne is with us you know i i
was a little surprised i saw this on fox
news dot com
mansion votes with bernie sanders 88 of
the time elizabeth warren 91 of the time
chuck schumer
91 of the time
you know just to give context to this
susan collins only votes with the
mcconnell 62 percent of the time
markowski 68 of the time lindsey graham
73 percent of the time so you can see
that manchin is pretty much a
a schumer biden democrat i mean he likes
to portray himself as a moderate his
voting record shows just the opposite
yeah he's done a great job at uh at
false promotion here you know sean i
really want to go after this bill and
the way that
uh that that just people need to
understand uh
the international energies
agency
uh which is a big international group of
folks who have a lot of power and july
they put out a supply chain uh report
for electric vehicles this is what the
world's going to need just to meet 20 30
goals we're going to need the world 50
more lithium mines
60 more nickel mines
17 more cobalt mines so these mines come
from
the cobalt comes from congo you ever see
videos of those kids seven-year-old kids
in filthy water for about eight hours a
day 12 hours a day no education pennies
on the dollar uh the the the lithium
some comes from australia some comes
from chile you got to poison the waters
to get it out of there
some comes from russia
indonesia you got the nickel
and the reason i'm bringing this up is
there are five stages to getting from
the raw material to the finished product
so when we talk about saving just think
of you where even if you love the
climate issue itself
the president is lying to you
this bill does nothing on the climate
side
what it means is that we're going to
continue to strip mine
the planet we're going to strip mine the
planet and poison the waters
so as you go along through the process
you got the materials you start to
process it russia takes a greater share
i mean china takes a greater share then
you do the cell components china takes a
greater share and then you get the
batteries this is the most important
part to remember
when the white house talks about energy
security i guess they're talking about
those batteries
right now china has a 77 share
in a couple of years they'll have an 80
percent share
our share will go from 9 to 6
the only part of this equation that we
play a role in is at the very end of it
we buy these things and you make the
point already we have the federal
government paying giving money to the
richest americans college grads who live
in in urban settings
to buy these cars they can afford them
on their own they don't need any
incentive certainly they don't need the
taxpayers money someone driving a cab
for a living
so this whole thing is a complete farce
there's nothing economic about it and it
does nothing zero zero to even save the
climate all right so you're the only
other person i know that's been talking
about this you're 100 right now an
electric vehicle on average costs 20
grand more than a gas powered vehicle
you're right so you have to mine for
nickel for cobalt for manganese and and
all these minerals you use big heavy
equipment to do so it's not
environmentally friendly in and of
itself uh then then you make these
batteries and how do you charge them 88
of our grid a power grid is not about
renewables only 12 is sure so using
natural gas and coal to charge your
electric vehicle
uh in your garage or your your charging
station and you pay more for that as
well so the bottom line is they're still
being fueled in that sense from mother
earth and fossil fuels and of course
you're right
you know mining all of these these areas
and destroying the environment in that
process
yeah we're not drilling a hole in the
ground and going you know a a few miles
down and cracking rocks we are stripping
the planet and poisoning the waters and
here's the crazy thing we just have to
look to europe france and germany their
electricity rates will be 1 000 percent
higher this winter 1 000 percent higher
than the average price for the last 10
years
so there are costs of this it's not
magic fairy dust we just don't say oh
it's an ev like some democratic congress
people believe i'm so glad i got an ev
i'm not suffering of course you're
suffering and by the way so is a small
business that can no longer afford the
electricity bill this thing is
absolutely devastating from one end to
another all this is is a money transfer
that's all this is we are transferring
money to the richest americans out there
progressives who vote for for
joe biden that's all this is
all right charles payne thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else